welcome to an edition of a beginner
breakdown I am your host Mike comer
today we'll be going over games from
odds staff training tournament so we'll
start off with a game played between the
lowest ranked player from the Chess Club
playing the best player from the world
chess Hall of Fame so a very exciting
game Ryan is our hero from the Chess
Club defending the enter the Chess Club
against Nick from the real chess Hall of
Fame so let's let's see how they do
okay so Ryan starts out with the King's
pawn up to excellent efore at Nick
counters a five all right you'll see
this a lot in beginner games so the
knight comes out to attack the pond and
so now Nick decides not to defend it
interesting
okay so Bishop to c4 attacks the pivotal
square f7 f7 is the weakest Square in
chess right because it's only defended
by the King so he brings out his own
Knight to f6 attacks the pawn and so now
how can white attack this pawn on f7
again
yes jamming the night night night the g5
okay so let's see if he's gonna do
anything about this
chances are looking nope Queen to e7 so
he did defend the pawn right but notice
the Knights were three the bishops were
three so that's six points and the nine
point piece is attacking it so what
should white do then we need to attack
it again or can we just simply take it
here we get yeah yeah yeah we take it
and hope yeah yeah hope that he takes me
back but they don't all right so so they
play play the move unfortunately d3 not
recommended go ahead and just take that
up pawn with Chuck when you have it do
it
alright so now he brings out his Knight
to g5 or to g4 excuse me so what can you
guys tell me about this night so it's in
our territory it's in White's camp
it's an undefended piece not not very
good so what can we do to this night
just chop it off the board just capture
it right so now so now we we got we're
up we're doing good all right so now he
decides to attack the knight so now the
Queen's attacking the knight the bishops
attacking the knight okay but how many
defenders do we have on it true and he's
got two attackers so so really it sure
looks like it's adequately defended we
have just as many defenders as he has an
attackers so we really don't have to do
anything about we could just proceed to
play Knight to c3
and maybe get Knight to d5 and
eventually so we really don't have to do
anything about it but now that his
Knights attacked he decides oh I can
finally take f7 however black and gets a
mighty big counter play with this true
our rook is under attack but now it's
time for black to make some good
captures and threats of his own yes do
you see it remember what white is hoping
that its Queen takes Knight because
unfortunately this Bishop comes down and
swoops the Queen off the board
what else can black capture the white
bishop yes so he comes down and takes
the bishop and now he's got his own
threat in mind
Bishop takes pawn so white takes the
rook and then black takes the pawn and
now this rook is in major jeopardy here
all right so now he gets a check in and
then King goes back to d8 notice that
the king and queen are on the same
diagonal but it doesn't matter because
the LightSquared Bishop is gone
all right so now white decides to the
castle by cancelling you move the King
over two spaces and the rook right next
to it so he just takes the other rook so
now he plays Queen to h3 aim for this
pawn here so now black plays c6 so if he
ever gets checked he's got an escape
path here all right so so you know we
attacked the H pawn he didn't do
anything about it
so we're gonna go through with our
threat and take it so now he wants to
try to get opened up here so he plays d5
and now we take g6 so when Knight takes
g6 now this is this is something you
guys gotta watch out for a lot is you
might just be thinking wow he just
wanted that pawn right so Knight takes
pawn
so just true the knight wanted to go to
g6 because it was capturing a pawn but
why else did he want to go to g6 to
attack the Queen good excellent but so
we need to be we need to see that all
right so our Queens under attack we
better move it alright so he does
excellent all right so now white decides
that he's up material or at least it
looks like he's up material daddy you
know now's a good time to trade pieces
but you know who's really doing the
attacking in this position white or
black why it's attacking so so maybe
it's not such a great idea
to trade Queens in this position because
we're you know we can thread some checks
blacks King is way less defended than
our King that's that's safe in this nice
castle so blacks queen really isn't that
big of a threat right now we're our you
know we could try to get a checkmate
going here somehow maybe maybe we just
take the pawn and then if pawn takes
back we'll take back with the bishop and
we'll be doing good but but white things
well I'm up I might as well trade so so
he plays Queen is now pinned to the king
so Queen takes all right he defends the
Queen fair enough so Queen takes check
Knight takes back and so now he got
another defender on this pawn here so
now white plays c3 which which the
concept isn't that bad but but he's got
no execution so why do you think
he played the move c3 the trap this
Bishop on a one great idea but you got
to calculate it's not going to work
because one these pawns are hanging and
now he's going to get in escape scares
because in in order for white to capture
this bishop on a one this rook has to do
it right in in order for the rook to
capture on a one does not has to move
and once this Knight moves guess what
the bishop is free to go to c3 and
capture the pawn so so even though you
might be like oh I've seen this concept
before I want to try it you got to make
sure that you can actually execute it
before you you play it like like that's
a great idea trapping a piece on the
back row but you got to make sure you
can do it
all right so instead you're just going
to get your position demolished okay so
now so now he's got to really probably
protect this pawn somehow instead he's
like I got a passed pawn let's just go
get it
you're only one two three four five away
from getting a Queen if you got a passed
pawn you know so so he's like I'm
four-way now it's a b6 so what do you
think whites should play now he should
just follow through with this plan he
should just play I played h4 you might
as well follow through with the plan no
reason to play bishop here I guess he
was preventing this bishop from coming
here and attacking the rook but hey you
know you just keep going with your plan
yes to get give them the check okay we
could do that and then he'll be like
okay I'll just I just go here it's like
we didn't get any
anything big for that as you'll see you
know if this night ever ventures to the
d2 for some reason you know we could be
like yeah we got a pin now okay that
would be see by checking this King off
this nice big open file we're limiting
our chances of tactics okay we're
actually just just getting this King
like safer for him you know and he
doesn't really have to spend a move
because we had to spend a move checking
him so he gets like a free move getting
out of the check into a safer area yeah
yeah like like like if you know if you
didn't come up with this h4 idea which I
mean it might it might work I mean it
might be crazy enough to work I don't
know you know you might want to play in
that position instead of h4 possibly
it's just like move it to where it's
attacking something so work here right
so now when this Knight moves well
unfortunately he could probably move to
g5 and bug your bishop but say this
Knight just moved to a ram square you
could win the pawn when he would
probably go to g5 here and attack your
bishop so yeah but you want it you want
to get him where he's either are an open
file or at least on a file where he's
like you know attacking something like
see pawn like this would be a good file
for him okay
but after h4 Ryan chose the two kind of
abandoned this h5 idea at least
temporarily for Bishop to c4
so now Knight takes the pawn okay so now
he captures it and now the bishop is
free so now black even though he was
getting decimated in the opening has
done a good
a good job getting back into the game
and so now rook check okay so so now
King just moves to safety here and now
he's gonna try to get this uh Queen
going all right so so Bishop to g4 if
Forks the pawn and the rook here okay
yeah I'm sure that's a wrap it's
thinking oh man
what's to do so now we need to come up
with some kind of threat here or else
our pawns gonna go bye-bye and all our
dreams are getting a queen as well so
rook the d3 good but so now let's see
see what's going on so our our dark
square Bishop is under attack now I'm in
the so now we got to really learn about
this when it's a good time to make
counter attacks and when it isn't okay
so our Bishop is under attack that's
true
so um to make just easy will be like
we'll just move it and then we're safe
okay or we can look for counter attacks
so what it would be a counter attack for
black here notice if you make a counter
attack meaning a counter attack is when
you don't address the situation at hand
like oh my God my bishops under attack a
counter attack is when you attack
something greater or equal to what's
currently being attacked so right now
our Bishop is being attacked so who can
we attack of white that is greater or
equal than the night
fantastic Bishop h5 okay so one we get
his passport which is excellent because
that's that's the whole reason well
report the upon and the rook in the
first place and now we're making a tack
greater or equal than two rook takes
Bishop right with Bishop takes Knight
now before we just do that we had to
calculate oh my god can this Knight do
anything like a crazy check or you know
thread our rook the answer is no so so
that would be a great execution of
making a threat greater or equal to your
opponent's sometimes it works out
sometimes it does it every situation is
different and you just have to calculate
it out in this situation Bishop takes h5
would be a great move
leaving your other Bishop hanging yes
yes yes so so basically you got four
points out of that the pawns worth one
the Knights worth three and white only
got a bishop out of there which is worth
three so he profited a point and that
that h-bomb was you know potentially
going to turn into a nine point piece as
we'll see spoiler alert
but yeah so so instead black decides man
my bishops attack I'm just gonna move it
alright so now so now White's just like
my pods are under attack I'm gonna move
it and so so black really got nothing
out of out of that nice fork that he did
okay so now he attacks this Bishop so so
like you could you could analyze it all
the time like should I just move it or
should I make a threat greater or equal
to it but more often than that it's
probably just simpler just to uh if your
pieces under attack just move it to
safety okay don't try and make anything
so complicated all right so now he
attacks the rook
so now we attack the bishop here bishop
attacks the knight but notice it's
defended so we're doing okay you just
keep pushing that pawn alright you
should notice he's now just worn away
but how many defenders does black have
on this h8 square like that gets this
queening square the rook and also the
bishop okay so he's doing a great job
defending this queening square this is
good good job
okay so he played that or a5 now how can
we try to get rid of one of his
defenders of this queening square so the
way we could get rid of you know
somebody defending the queening square
is one we could remove them from the
board or maybe we could interpose a
piece in between their piece and the
queening square but we got 7 so if we
play our way Knight to e7 we do attack
the bishop but unfortunately all he just
took our precious past pawn and in the
endgame these past pawns are like gold I
mean they're they're ready they're ready
to be cast in for you know a queen here
so you're doing great so you really
don't want to lose those past pawns in
the endgame especially they advance past
pawns
because they're so close yeah well we
could attack it the best job well
well we could do we could just take the
night maybe
and then Brooke tanks and then we'll
just get our rook right on that queening
square just like yeah well whatever we
don't want to do that though maybe we'll
put our Bishop on the queening square
yeah maybe yeah I like Bishop on the
Queen's group cuz because you'll see
when you see the extra move he could he
could do it in this variation as well so
so what but I don't like give away the
move just yet all right all right so now
we're onto something a version a report
them on the Queen in square of course
here would just get captured well well
unfortunately the pawn couldn't capture
forward he can only capture diagonal
which is a pity yeah okay so so does
anybody so there's no way we can ever
stop this this dude well maybe we could
35 okay all right so now you're now
you're kind of on to something but look
we already gave up a whole night to do
that so that it just doesn't add up
because he could just be like them he
all he has to do is play King here and
he protects his rook and then if we take
King takes your pawns not going anywhere
very good yeah then the rook will take
the rook rook takes Bishop Oh
after King be seven make the worst thing
black could do in this position is take
the rook right everybody see that
because then all the whites dreams come
true
so so all he would do is protect the
rook and then after rook takes the
bishop rook takes and it's not looking
very good for white here and his pawns
gonna get captured on the next move okay
okay here we go
how about Bishop to g8 oh he said I
wrote the g8 and now we have now the
rook is no longer defending the key
queening square here of a eight and so
that's that's what we would need to do
and that's right we wouldn't ever want
to get our rook back there I'll say we
get trapped too so so that should be our
White's idea here is h7 a5 Bishop here
and then with the next move being Queen
so actually his best move was probably
take rook takes and then we can play
like rook well with ideas of rook here
maybe you could play bishop there though
so we get but then we just start pushing
this guy and we'll be will be good but
those are some ideas you can have so
work the g5 was actually played in the
game Bishop back to d7 and now he plays
our King f1 all right
the pawn attacks the bishop so he still
doesn't see the this Bishop move
unfortunately he decides to attack the
pawn here Rick protects the pawn King up
to stop it so he's moving his King
around here so notice that they're not
really trying to get this guy guy up
right now
no King III and he's trying to get his
own past pond down here so Bishop takes
the pawn putting his bishop in a pin
here and now he's got the big fork here
Bishop King rook so it's looking pretty
bad for for white here what you know no
fear you know so what would everybody
play is black in this position yeah
everybody can just shout it out
Bishop takes the rook right and that
that is actually what is played okay he
did take the rook okay excellent
so now desperate times call for
desperate measures right you just took
our work we might as well get this Queen
finally right Queen all right so now
everybody can shout out what what do you
think blacks you play in this position
take the Queen right thank the Queen
rook takes Queen and then Knight takes
rook and because these guys are more
advanced it looks like black will have
the edge I mean he's got to get these
pawns going fast then it's not gonna be
fast enough but instead he decides you
know what I can't I can't I can't waste
the move taking his Queen I'm gonna try
to go get my own Queen right no well
actually not right now first he's gonna
play his Bishop back the c1 yeah always
take their Queen if the guy's got a
queen and you have another piece and you
can take it take it it's always a good
move right and so now he sees a check so
he plays a check because it's cool yeah
and then he's like oh I give up I'm in
check it's over why didn't I take the
why did I take the Queen it's always
take that quick all right so next up is
a game I got to play in the tournament
I was playing the black pieces against
Clayton Clayton is an actor so it's very
exciting what's the key to control that
flip the board I've got white
all right so Clayton's starts out Queens
pulling up to so I counter with Knight
f6 so the whole reason why I played
Knight f6 is because when they play d4 I
know that they want to eventually play E
for all right and it's my job to make
sure that they can't and if they do it
will get taken so I guess he could play
you forward but but I would just take it
all right so claim plays c4 by c6 Knight
up three d5 all right now now claiming
boxes and his Bishop with the move III
all right and now I get my Bishop free
of the pawn chain by pinning the night
so clean plays Knight B 2 2 2 it to
protect the UH night here and now I play
East 6th US solidify my pawn chain here
Bishop e2 Bishop d6 plays h3 to attack
my bishop
so my bishops attacked so you think all
my bishops attack I'll just take it or
do you think my bishops attacked but I
like that you know I got so much
pressure on with the Bishop I'll just
move them back and keep the pressure on
that's what I play so just go somebody's
under attack you know if you like your
plan don't don't stop your plan just
cause they're attacking alright so he
castles so I get castled
and so now he plays Bishop to d3 so so
if you notice in this position you know
after I play rook e8 you know I mean
we're both doing okay
I be on my Bishop mountain his pomp my
pawn chain he doesn't you know we're
both fighting for the center but now he
plays efore here okay so when he plays
efore what is his big threat here g5
yeah yeah yeah so so yeah yeah that's
something a lot of people need to you
know watch out for is when they push the
pawn they might be attacking something
but that might be not to be their only
agenda why they push the pawn they might
be doing it so they can push the pawn
some more okay all right so ePHI so so
in this position I should just take and
then take and you know he's doing okay
he's got a four in so that was good on
him and things are going okay for both
of us instead I play Bishop to c7 and
that just really cramps my style here so
he plays a five attacks the night so I
got to move it and I got to move it
backwards all right so now I'm getting
really cramped because I didn't make a
pivot exchange when I should have so
Queen to c2 excellent putting the Queen
and Bishop and a battery attacking h7 so
you could play h6 here what would be
wrong with g6 here yeah excellent white
plays d4 and my bishop is tripped so the
easiest way is just to play bishop here
because same thing with h6 if we
calculate
he can play g4 and then my only move is
to retreat the bishop back and notice I
only have one defender he's
one two attackers the Queen's attacking
the bishop through an x-ray so so really
my only solution is Bishop to g6 sorry
he doesn't double my pawns and he plays
Knight to b3 I'm like I'm oh well okay
so I take the pawn here hoping that he
takes bishop takes right and then I went
as Queen but he sees it so he takes with
the Queen and then I play Knight to b6
hoping that he goes to c3 because if he
goes to c3 then I play Knight to d5 and
really then I'm hoping again that he
plays Queen to c2 and then what move do
I play that makes all my dreams come
true his dreams come true knight to e3
but we're getting there we got the right
idea
attack the Queen what's the only other
square that I can go to that attacks the
Queen besides III b4 and notice Queens
attack and the bishop is now double
attack so I he would move it and then I
would take it but a lot of Hope chests
and he doesn't fall for really any of it
he plays Queen back to c2 immediately
and so I'm like okay I will take it in
Queen tastes even though claims made a
lot of Queen moves the last couple moves
it really hasn't hurt his position at
all so now there's a key key part in
this game look look at my king it's in a
castle right and I got three little guys
in front of it but is there anybody else
trying to defend this castle at all no
no and when there's no defenders on a
castle he needs to hurry up and try to
checkmate me as fast as he can right
Knight to g5 like I might play a six you
play Knight to g5 threaten checkmate and
get it on okay
so I need to get somebody of mine okay
look at all my
ESA's over to the kingside as fast as
possible
any ideas the excellent 98 2d SAP
okay because now when he plays if you
were to play Knight to g5 so it's a
attacks McQueen so I move it he moves it
and now I can get well eventually I can
get my knight to f8 as you'll see and
help defend all this stuff but first
things first I want to my bishop is a
piece of junk right because I were
treating him so much and he's he's
blocked behind white spawns so I want to
trade this Bishop for that Bishop
instead he just plays h4 and a and
protects it so now I get my knight in to
f8 okay I'm protecting h7 without my
knight holding on to this position it'd
be tough so Knight to c5 okay so if we
watched the second video I ever did on
this YouTube channel double pawns and
holes you would know exactly where a
white knight would want to get to in
this position now give you a hint it's
not c5 where would a knight love to be
in this position I'll give you a hint
it's in a hole a hole is any square on
the board that cannot be attacked by an
enemy pawn
yes and and the best holes are supported
okay so so if this Knight really wants
to be on d6 you know for keen my queen
and my rook I don't even know if we
would even trade this beautiful night
for this rook in this position okay I
mean this Knight is just so good right
but he's not on d6 yet so I play Knight
to d5 so I'm in a hole but it's in my
territory my the hole is in my territory
you see it can't be kicked away by any
pawns and it's not it's not
that good and so Clayton just says a
three you're never gonna go to be four
fine
alright so Bishop e7 so now I'm almost
encouraging him for his night to go away
so Bishop takes the rook rook takes so
so okay we know we want a knight and d6
right so let's get them there ASAP even
if it's not a fort like it's not forking
anything it's still really awesome and
really cramping my style that uh this
Knight is in d6 so how would we get a
Knight to d6 in two moves here anybody
he 494 it it's just okay we just need to
jump to a spot that you know can jump
the d6 and see how awesome that night
would be here and then so let's say we
did that okay and whatever I just waste
the moves and then you know I might try
to to get that night away by getting my
night on c8 and by then we can put our
knight here and then on e4 so whenever
we trade a knight a Black Knight for a
white knight we could just replace it
with the other night and where you just
be like superstars you know so that's
what you want to look for it but he
never finds that idea and unfortunately
loses the game so he plays Knight to g5
here what does he think he's threatening
he thinks he's threatening checkmate but
is he no because my knight that night on
the background is doing so good alright
so so now I can just say go away so he
goes away so obviously he should retreat
the e4 and go here but okay so it goes
aged three and then Queen to d8 so
sneaky move Queen to d8 what am i
attacking through an x-ray with Queen to
d8 what is this Queen in the same Lane
as
it's an enemy piece or pond who is the
queen aiming at the pawn right so you
got to watch out for that
alright so Queen to g3 tax the pawn rook
c7 alright look to e4 so now things are
getting serious so so when he plays rook
to e4 where do you think this book's
gonna go the next move
g4 thank you alright so so we need to
anticipate their moves all right luckily
we could play Knight to e7 here so if
the rook does go to g4 here what move
can we do to protect g7 and attack one
of a whites major pieces g6
unfortunately so so if we play it one of
our Knights to g6 he's got this this
move and that was like oh man I don't
want to move it because now I'm gonna
get check so so that was a good idea to
try to get them in the way but there's
an actual way instead of giving the
knight in the way he can actually
protect g7 so when if the rook takes it
I could just scoop it back with the
night
this guy f5 yes yes so Knight f5 is is
the move here okay and then then the the
Queen would have to move to a safety
here
yes yes yes so so after 97 yeah I guess
he sees it and so he plays Knight to f4
so now I attack it anyway and it's a
double attack here okay
attacking the pawn so Queen to h3 and
then Queen takes the pawn Queen takes
Knight takes so now notice that this
Knight is in the same line as this rook
so it's almost like we have a free move
here right with this Knight because
wherever this Knight goes the work would
take it but we want to try to get the
most bang for the buck when we make
these uh but they're called discovered
attacks right right it's white to move
yep so this night and this Knight in the
rook they're all on the same rank the
fourth rank here so is there anything
that this Knight can capture
why tonight
yeah II six Knight takes c6 so then if I
take back well however I take back well
let's say let's just say I take back
with the opponent or whatever then rook
can take the knight
so it's ideas like that we always got to
be looking for now I calculated this out
that if you want to play Knight takes c6
I would have snuck in Knight to f3 check
and then he he would get double pawns
Knight takes Knight takes pawn takes and
now we'd have the same number of pawns
but like in the last game I'd have that
passed H pawn you know and maybe I can
turn it into a queen you know so so
those are ideas you need to be looking
for if guys are on the same leg but he
plays Knight to h5 which doesn't have
any force right because true my Knights
under attack but I'm just going to move
it to safety and everything's going to
be fine
alright so Knight back grilka attacks
the pawn this is where we want the rooks
right on those open files finally you
know our semi open files attacking stuff
so he plays f4 so where do you think I
want this other rook like not maybe not
in this position but where do you think
I would ultimately want him probably
here right but unfortunately you can't
go here because my knight would take us
so you just say get out of here
so the Knights out and now we can play
our rook here and now we got two guys
attacking the pawn he was smart he play
Knight e 2 instead he played the move I
thought he would play rook the d1 so so
now's their time to strike now this
point is in something right a pin right
because if this pawn ever moves off the
the rook will take the rook right so
what move do you think you play here
yeah move the point of attack pin pieces
can't get any more simple than that and
notice he can't play d5 here because you
know I still have way more attackers
than he has defenders so he tries to
play f5 hoping that I would take even if
I take he's still well he could play
Knight takes pawn defend now you get
another defender so so it was a decent
try for him but I didn't fall for it
so after f5 just moved my knight back to
e7 and so now after Knight h5 he just
lets that pawn go so Knight takes pawn
and now the game is pretty much over
cuz now he plays g3 so in this final
position here we have many ways to take
this pawn right how should we though so
we could play Knight takes and if we
play like this it's probably not too bad
because we're hoping for like or in the
next move if he doesn't do anything
night check so so that might be ok or he
might be like well you know what I'm
just going to move my rook somewhere and
well not there obviously or else you'll
get forked but maybe night work here and
maybe he can try to generate an attack
on this F file then alright so so what
we want to do here is absence since
we're up a couple pawns now we want to
just consolidate everything as fast as
possible so we play rook takes so even
if he plays like in the game
rook here we can just take take and
we're just consolidating pieces down
so it's a it's yeah we can't even get my
check yeah and then we got we got it all
coming then you know just take all the
stuff then okay so yeah you want to just
trade pieces when you got a a winning
endgame like that